hey this is kind of interesting so a
couple weeks ago
i told you that for a while i've been
mulling over
how could we introduce a spanish
language version
of the david pakman show into the online
political milieu
so to speak the idea being there's lots
of people in the united states
whose english is not good enough to
really take in
uh political content like the normal
english language version of the david
pakman show
so if there was some way to do a version
of the david pakman show
in spanish we would be reaching a
completely new audience now it's not
practical i don't have the time in the
day in a literal sense to do the entire
show over
in my native language of spanish
remembering of course that i was born in
argentina
and learned english as a second language
so one idea that i presented a couple of
weeks ago was doing
a computer like an automated computer
overdub of the show in a computerized
spanish voice and the problem was it
sounded pretty unnatural let me play a
little bit of that for you just to
remind you
e foreign
so i asked for feedback on that and the
feedback was
almost unanimous i mean i can't think of
any time when feedback has been so
overwhelmingly united on anything people
were overwhelmingly
positive about the idea of a spanish
version of the david pakman show
but the consensus was that auto dub
technology
is not the way to do it it's just not
not dynamic enough
it doesn't sound anything like the
program or like me
with dynamics in my speech so i tabled
it because
the alternative is to get a real person
to dub every day what we're doing
that's expensive it's a ton of work and
maybe it's outside of our scope
cut to this week when a reddit user and
a viewer of the show
actually did a real dub of a david
pakman show clip now
the time it took is crazy it took him
four hours for like a two or three
minute clip
um but it's actually really good so take
a look at this take a listen this isn't
even
uh um it's it's sort of funnier
in a sense because this was a voicemail
segment from the eggman
and he translates eggman as ombre huevo
literally eggman i mean as a literal
translation i just don't know why i find
that hilariously endearing we'll play
just a little bit of this
of this take a listen um
i truly have no idea how we could make
this a thing
but i think it does have potential the
the reality is
you know professional daily dubbing of
the entire show
would be i i think extraordinarily
expensive the idea is not to fill our
current channel
with spanish language content but my my
thought was
to create you know the david pakman show
in spanish and to have
spanish versions of our clips there um
also part of why this is funny to me is
that me being from argentina
my spanish accent is so different from
this viewer who's from somewhere
not argentina or uruguay they don't
sound like they're from spain i can't
quite place the accent it doesn't sound
puerto rican or dominican but it sounds
could be anything from mexico to
colombia or venezuela something like
that
that's also just kind of funny to me
although i guess it'd be less funny
to people who don't speak spanish anyway
let me know what you think about this i
think it is a very very cool idea
uh i mean i think like the dream would
be someone
in argentina can give us some really
great rate on dubbing the entire day's
clips
so it would be in an argentinian accent
maybe because of the exchange rate it
would be more affordable
i don't know in any case i really
appreciate this one clip being dubbed
and a really really nice job
if you have other ideas for what we
might be able to do on this let me know
i think that there is value and
listen this is not just i mean i think
to be very clear
i actually think that the value of doing
this type of content
in spanish but for american politics is
that
we could really be reaching an entire
new audience that doesn't feel like they
have content like this
that is in their wheelhouse
linguistically based on
the the level at which they they do or
maybe don't speak english so
there's tons of programs in argentina in
spanish about argentinian politics
there's tons of program programs in
mexico
in spanish about mexican politics but my
idea is that this is really an untapped
market
i mean i don't know that any of the
other progressive online shows are even
thinking about this i'm thinking about
it because i'm an immigrant from
argentina
and i talk to so many people all the
time just people i meet out in the world
who would love to be following american
politics
in spanish from a progressive
perspective but
there is not as much available as maybe
they would like so i'm actually seeing
this as an activism tool
in addition to just being kind of
interesting and different